[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno nuestro nombre es para palabras
para palabras es una agrupación como se
pueden dar cuenta de instrumentos de
viento acompañado por un percusionista o
un baterista en este caso
quisiéramos contarle un poco de la
historia brevemente de nuestra música
de lo que ha pasado con los instrumentos
de viento y cómo se han desarrollado
quisiéramos primero
[Música]
hablar de la primera parte de nuestro
nombre nuestro nombre se compone de
digamos de dos palabras que se juntan
una es la papayera y la otra es una
palabra en inglés brass que traduce
metal
con que se fabrican los instrumentos el
material con que se fabrican los
instrumentos que ejecutamos
muchos se preguntarán de dónde viene ese
término de papayera
como costeños como colombianos que
siempre le sacamos una segunda parte a
todos
la papaya era el término papayera hay
muchas versiones que cuentan de dónde
salió este término
voy a comentarles algunas para entrar en
contexto
hay una que habla de nuestros
antepasados nuestros campesinos cuando
hacían sus labores en el campo y
descansaban a mediodía ellos acompañaban
su momento de descanso con una flauta
que hacían con la el fututo de la papaya
que llaman ejes como la el palito de la
de la hoja de la papaya eso es es un
algo natural que es hueco como los
instrumentos
la hacían unos huequitos les colocaban
una especie de lengüeta con una hoja y
hacían una flauta y comenzaban a hacer
melodías ahí para acompañar el rato de
descanso
posterior a eso cuando llegaron los
instrumentos de viento a la al caribe a
colombia
estos mismos campesinos empezaron a
a tocar instrumentos de viento y
aquellas melodías que hacían en esos
instrumentos rústicos
pasaban a los instrumentos de viento y
ahí comenzaron a llamar dicen algunos
empezaron a adoptar el término papayera
otra otra historia se remonta por allá a
los años 40 en barranquilla cuando
las fiestas de los pueblos las fiestas
religiosas
eran amenazadas por los músicos que
tocaban instrumentos de viento
los músicos de las bandas militares como
ustedes saben el uniforme pues el
camuflado de las fuerzas militares
siempre es verde y entonces la gente
empezó a empezó a comparar y empezó a
decir ah
allá vienen los papayeros los papayeros
compañeros y empezaron a tomar adoptar
el nombre como papayera y la última
historia habla de el asocio que hacen
las personas que hacía la gente en
aquella época en el siglo pasado del
canto del ave del papayero con los
toques de los instrumentos de viento
eso es algo más o menos de donde se
desprende la palabra papaya era que
algunos hoy día nos gustan de esa
palabra porque se sienten denigrado se
sienten excluidos
por ejemplo la gente de las sábanas que
es donde más se desarrolla este tipo de
música folklórica ellos a muchos no les
gusta el término papayera ellos
prefieren llamarlos bandas habaneras
bandas playeras o bandas tradicional
luego de esto
[Música]
podemos hablar un poco de lo que sucede
con esta formación qué es una formación
muy fácil de transportar a cualquier
lugar y en épocas pasadas cuando no
había grandes amplificación es que
podrían amplificar una voz que podrían
amplificar una guitarra un violín este
estos eran los instrumentos que
amenizaban las fiestas y por eso la
banda
tiene tanto arraigo tiene tiene tanta
conexión con el pueblo porque era la
música que disfrutaba la gente de la
calle las festividades en la calle
diferente a los violines diferente a las
puertas que necesitaban un teatro que
tuviese buena acústica para que los
violines se pudieran escuchar etcétera
etcétera
de ahí es donde nosotros adoptamos tanto
la banda y queremos tanto la banda
tradicional pero qué pasa no solamente
en colombia la banda es es querida es
tradicional en muchas otras partes del
mundo por las circunstancias que hablé
anteriormente adoptaron la banda para
sus festividades entonces muchos lugares
del mundo hoy día todavía se conserva
esa tradición de tener una banda pero
qué pasa en el resto del mundo no se
llama papayera ni banda tradicional sino
que se le conoce como brass band que es
una banda de brass es una banda de
bronces las encontramos en new orleans
en mexico hay muchas bandas
y tradicionales que tengan su música e
incluso meten voces también tantas en
cantantes y
todo esto todo este bagaje que ha tenido
la música de los instrumentos de viento
en el mundo nosotros quisimos integrarla
a lo nuestro hicimos una fusión y por
eso nuestro nombre para palabras porque
queremos fusionar
cualquier música del mundo que se haga o
no se haga con instrumentos de metal
incluirla y de esta forma darle un aire
diferente a nuestros instrumentos
tradicionales a nuestro a nuestra banda
con esto no queremos decir que la banda
que hoy día vive que son las bandas
tradicionales son mejores o peores la
tradición siempre va a ser la tradición
y siempre le vamos a tener un inmenso
respeto
pero nosotros como músicos modernos
sentimos la necesidad de expresarnos
diferente e incluso de vestirnos
diferente y hacer música para la gente
joven
que se identifique es la hora que
nosotros a veces hemos tocado en
quinceañeros y la quinceañera todavía
dice este papá llera será posible que yo
gocé mi quinceañero una papayera mami tú
quisiste mami como esto ocurre a ti eso
los pacos rollo
y los hemos convencido entonces ahí poco
a poco vamos consiguiendo el objetivo
entonces por ejemplo vamos a hacer un
ejemplo musical hay un tema que está muy
de moda que nosotros adaptamos y con
esto la juventud goza quiero que lo
escuchen es algo más o menos así
[Música]
y
ah
e
muchas gracias y apuesto que lo que
aplaudieron son de 20 años para abajo si
o no saben bueno
entonces cuál es la otra táctica tenemos
tenemos otra táctica
tratamos de incluir en los temas
internacionales
folclor una parte donde introducimos
algo de porro verdad y hacemos
lo contrario con la música de acá cuando
tocamos un tema de acá tratamos de meter
fondo tratamos de meter pop y vamos
haciendo ahí la mezcla
entonces seguimos el patrón de muchos de
muchos maestros
que hoy día hacen parte del historial de
la música colombiana porque se
encargaron de hacer fusiones por ejemplo
pacho galán y lucho bermúdez trajeron a
colombia el formato de big band
en esa época nadie lo conocía y pacho
galán hizo con una big band al estilo
norteamericano música del caribe música
de colombia igual el maestro lucho
bermúdez igual como ha hecho carlos
vives con el vallenato por gracias a
carlos vives el vallenato se conoce en
todo el mundo porque puyol acordeón la
lleno de guitarras y rock y tal y la
gente oye mira que bacano que hay ahí
vino esos vallenato y ping la sacó del
estadio el hombre y además de eso
nuestra otra táctica es el instrumento
que ustedes ven ahí es un instrumento
que se ha hecho mundialmente famoso que
es la batería
la batería es un instrumento que
reemplaza el trabajo de
lo que hacen muchos músicos pero el
encargado de explicar eso es el
baterista de la banda el hijo de la niña
beti jai leer fontalvo sarmiento
buenas noches
[Música]
pues que no ha escuchado una batería en
cualquier género que nos gusta todo es
un instrumento referente en todos los la
mayoría de los géneros que escuchamos y
algo que nosotros comenzamos a hacer era
reemplazar esos tres instrumentistas de
percusión que existen en la banda
tradicional y que un percusionista y
baterista ejecuta los tres ritmos
en uno solo entonces esto es esto se
viene dando desde que pacho galán y
todos estos artistas colombianos
maestros colombianos que hemos tenido
con sus instrumentistas de percusión
comenzaron a crear lo que fueron estos
ritmos y esta adaptaciones a estos
instrumentos que no son de nosotros y se
fue evolucionando entonces le vamos a
hacer una pequeña muestra de lo que se
hace con los tres instrumentistas y la
reducción que desea hacia la batería
ah
[Música]
verde
[Aplausos]
y pues lo que se lleva a la batería pues
el bombo lo toma este redoblante y el
brillo acá y es algo así
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
muchísimas gracias
nos despedimos con este tema espero que
se pongan de pie y bailen con nosotros
se van a bailar
algo muy importante para terminar todo
esto lo hacemos en favor de la música
entonces que viva la música y que viva
la música colombiana
entonces este mosaico se van a sentir la
vida 40 el sábado de carnaval para que
la basílica
[Música]
él
sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o no
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]